[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv 78 aujourd'hui un v y
paix consacré à gabriel à bodart et
cheney rebonjour sur ce plateau vous
êtes chef de choeur vous dirigez depuis
2015 et coeur de la pléiade une chorale
adultes à saint quentin en yvelines
nous arrivons sur les fêtes de fin
d'année c'est une période de
prédilection un petit peu pour votre
activité pour vous il ya beaucoup de
sollicitations en ce moment les chorales
on les redécouvre à chaque fois au
moment des périodes de fêtes oui c'est
une occasion de chanter
et puis il faut chanter et rechanter sur
l'amour sur la paix tout ce que période
que nous nous suggérer et puis donner
aussi un peu de chaleur humaine ceux qui
ceux qui sont un petit peu plus
marginalisées donc il vient au concert
ils chantent ils ont les petits cadeaux
voilà donc c'est important de donner je
vais parler un petit peu d'invités
d'actualité justement vous serez donc
sur la scène à l'église notre dame ne
mord pas le 2 décembre à 16 heures à
l'église saint-georges également de
trappes le 9 décembre à 16h les dates
vont se réafficher bien sûr à l'antenne
par lennon petit peu de ses
représentations du spectacle noël autour
du monde voilà la fiche nous à l'auto du
monde c'est à dire que dans une partie
de concert nous allons affronter
effectivement des chants des différentes
pays où on fête noël donc les champs
d'euros possible mais deux chambres de
dinde des haies
des chants en langue française aussi
donc un petit os de monde et avons
beaucoup de chance cela paie de la peste
ce serait une représentation aussi avec
la maîtrise d enfant de trappes
il ya des enfants ou plus en plus avec
les adultes comment ça se passe comment
vous travaillez aussi avec les enfants
c'est différent à l'oreille à une fois
par semaine la répétition lundi soir
avec les pléiades donc le choeur
d'adultes et lundi en fin d'après-midi à
la 18 heures donc la pub à l'école de
musique de trappes géré groupe trentaine
d'accords et qui vient surtout des
écoles où il était déjà initiés ils ont
fait il faisait partie d'un autre
spectacle avec un peu mais ce qu la
plupart du temps donc elle les enfants
vient de ces classes qui ont envie de se
perfectionner de chanter davantage et
donc avec eux on a un programme un peu
plus poussée et puis on fait ce qu'on
sait rien fait d'autre concerne aussi
dans l'année il est des adultes qui
viennent et qui n'ont jamais chanté vous
partez de zéro avec eux mais oui mais
oui et les enfants aussi donc c'est le
défi de chaque année d'intégrer les
nouveaux nouvelle cette maîtrise de
trappes poules avait créé avec la pms qu
l'association de promotion de la musique
quelle était la volonté justement
derrière c'était à la fois de
perfectionner ce qui en avaient besoin
puis de faire découvrir aux autres
exactement et les enfants qui ont
découvert dans l'école grâce à ce projet
d'app et msq opéré adore les écoles le
champ qui est qu'ils aient suivi ou
qu'ils ont envie de continuer à se
perfectionner dans la maîtrise de
trappes qui est une structure donc pour
les enfants motivés c'est pas des offres
exceptionnelles ils font pas de solfège
enfin deux quand même un petit peu avec
eux sur place mais c'est libre à tout le
monde
vous parlez de la musique la chorale
c'est aussi un lieu de rencontre de
partage des changes mais oui c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique c'est tomber
la barrière on tombe le masque et on se
livre c'est difficile c'est difficile
c'est difficile mais on se sent pas seul
et 7,7 euros contre humain c'est un
conte musical c'est le plaisir de
chanter le plaisir de la polyphonie
chanter ah
à plusieurs voix et le respect de
l'autre
et quand on est à côté de l'autre on
chante ensemble
lesquels sont plus proches donc on se
livre davantage et on souffre le plus au
monde à l'autre c'est formidable on va
parler un petit peu de vous à présent au
cours de cette émission vous avez une
solide formation formé au conservatoire
national en hongrie parlez nous un peu
de cette période
bah on a beaucoup de travail et c'est
tout on a fait plein de choses pour être
chef de choeur on a fait beaucoup de
piano brut chant l'histoire de la
musique
la théorie l'harmonisation les
instruments perd que franck logique et
c'est donc ce qu'il faut pour être chef
et de psychologie
vous avez grandi dans la musique oui
vous avez baigné dans la musique votre
pasteur il chantait votre mère était
organiste à l'église elle jouer du jazz
exactement je me suis bien renseigné vue
et donc c'était ma maison ça veut dire
tous les jours il y avait des chances
que vous viviez dedans que tous les
jours le bain on a là une fois par
semaine à l'église et dès qu'on pouvait
ont préparé des petits morceaux pour
l'orgue et d'autres mamans jouait du
piano
dimanche après-midi le jazz on allait à
l'école de musique régulièrement polis
et pourquoi la chorale en ce qui vous
concerne
quand vous êtes tourné vers les coeurs
dans la chorale bas anglais dans tous
les écolos chante donc c'était évident
qu'il y avait un grand cola d'enfants à
l'école de musique à l'école primaire et
au lycée aussi et à partir de ça c'est
faisait partie de ma vie vous dire en
gris il ya le champ qui a fait partie du
quotidien pour les pour les élèves c'est
un peu moins le cas en france et dans
d'autres pays vous le déplorez vous
pensez que ça pourrait aussi être
quelque chose de positif a développé
j'imagine un cessna très très important
tous les enfants besoin de la musique
pour leur développement harmonieux pour
leur bien être n'en parlons pas
développer les qualités musicaux
évidemment mais juste pour le plaisir et
je sors d'une école il aimait transition
ces enfants sont difficiles mais
juliette on me fait une ils ont dit
c'est génial dont j'ai géré fin on a
juste communiquer par la musique
donc moi je pense que si on touche à cet
âge les enfants avant dix ans au zoo et
ben c'est cette une autre génération une
autre enfant qui grandit dans la joie de
la musique
et puis il découvre l'art et découvrir
la musique découvrir entrer dans l'art
dans la beauté par le chant par son
propre show n'est pas plus touchants et
vous avez beaucoup voyagé aussi au maroc
région parisienne donc aujourd'hui la
chine l'inde aussi pourquoi ces voyages
déjà ben j'étais dans la valise des mots
magiques et donc il vous en avez besoin
les clubs professionnels
valade les premiers 20 ans c'était oui
je me suis marié que marocaine donc on a
vécu 20 ans formidables et puis après on
a continué donc en chine
mon mari était diplomate dans la culture
et donc on est là on a découvert la
culture chinoise les collants chinoise
des écoles chinoises où les enfants sont
deux heures debout pendant les
répétitions
puisqu'il n'ya pas de chaise pourquoi et
au nom d' où il connaissait pas du tout
la musique classique mais c'est très
fort la musique indienne et donc
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants qui voulait
apprendre et
la musique classique on a créé beaucoup
de coeur aussi pour le west and music
à chaque fois vous avez eu envie de
développer juste un mot une chorale de
d'apprendre la musique des lieux de
partage et la vôtre aussi
oui oui ça pousse à l'ag a pris beaucoup
de poids que peu de musique chinoise peu
de musique indienne parce que il y avait
une demande et puis j'avais envie de
donner puisque j'ai reçu donc on partage
les urnes enrichissement ça a changé
votre parcours aussi après dans
aujourd'hui par exemple ce que vous
apprenez ce que vous faites apprendre
aux élèves même aux adultes aux jeunes
et aux adultes
vous avez l'impression de vous être
nourris de ces expériences-là de ses
passages là dans les différents pays
déjà que les enfants sont différents de
réaction et c'est là et puis tout ce
qu'on a vécu musicalement aussi
évidemment c'est dans la poche dans les
doigts dans la voix donc voilà et je
suis heureuse d'être en france et
apprendre ça maintenant c'est
aujourd'hui encore vous ouvrez pour
l'étranger est ce qu'il vous arrive de
retourner dans ces pays de travailler
encore avec eux ou vous consacrer toute
votre activité ici dont les images
étaient les thoniers en chine pour une
formation
j'y retourne régulièrement au maroc pour
la formation des professeurs de musique
en egypte j'ai un projet avec les profs
de musique qui appelons la méthode co
die
voilà donc j'y retourne en egypte au
mois de février pour vous la musique
c'est toute votre vie et ça va continuer
encore longtemps
s'il se perd j'espère bien il vous reste
des choses à accomplir encore est-ce que
vous avez des projets des choses que
vous n'avez pas réussi à mener encore eh
bien vous savez que nous avons à anglet
la m
d'ailleurs c'est une façon de découvrir
la musique et c'est une façon de
découvrir à tout le monde à faire
découvrir et moi j'ai un projet que je
voudrais commencer à sous une forme ou
l'autre a créé les groupes des classes
godaille pour semer un petit peu cette
méthode et puis si je pouvais encore
formé quelques enseignants qui vont
suivre
mais pas seul à jarry c'est quoi cette
méthode vous pouvez nous en parler nous
expliquer un peu ça concerne la méthode
en quelques mots se bat sur le champ sur
le chant folklorique c'est à dire que
l'enfant
ce fable il réalise avec ses racines
musicaux avec sa langue la langue
française il y à des jeux des exercices
ludiques pour apprendre des rythmes et
mélodies les utilisations des gestes de
la main doré mis fin à ce moment là
c'est nous et c'est râpé à deux voix
puis à trois voies sont écrire les
choses dont beaucoup de travail
d'oreilles beaucoup de choses les faits
aurait déduit de pratique est toujours
des chansons des jeux des éditions d
écoute de musique dans quelque chose de
l'activ ça passe beaucoup par le jeu
mais oui mon jeu tout le temps fait les
deux villes est on fait des choses sans
fin au fait la dictée mais enfin on
appelle ça autrement
donc les enfants suis et ce qui est
important que tous les enfants puissent
accéder au moins les bases et puis
jusqu'à certain niveau avec cette
méthode qui
qui les élève plutôt au lieu de dire que
dansent et chantent faux donc on
encourage tout le monde
avec cette méthode peu d'ail on va
arriver à la fin de cet entretien juste
une chose que je n'ai pas précisé vous
êtes chevalier des arts et des lettres
tout de même pour la contribution à la
diffusion de la culture française à
l'étranger
vous avez une certaine fierté l'avoir
obtenu cette distinction et vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui de véhicules et 7
cette culture aussi n'est pas uniquement
française d'ailleurs on l'a entendue à
travers votre parcours
cette richesse j'ai dit là je suis pas
fier c'était ma vie depuis 40 ans gevrey
pour la musique pour la musique à
travers la langue française qu'ils m'ont
donné cette gentille mais avec ou sans
toute façon je continuerai ma vie et ma
mission je pense que représentation à
l'église notre-dame de maurepas le 2
décembre à 16h et puis l'église
saint-georges de trappes le 9 décembre à
16 heures il ya d'autres représentations
d'autres spectacles qui sont prévus dans
les prochaines semaines au-delà de ces
deux dates
nos connaissances vous êtes concentrés
sur cette activité là où est-ce qu'on
peut juste une dernière question au
rejoindre la chorale que soit du tout
pour dan et de deux mois de janvier avec
les adultes nous chantons la crème de
brahms question bon rousseau magnifique
et les enfants vont faire programme
choeurs d'opéras de pinocchio et d'autre
et est donc venu venir la pléiade merci
encore à vous d'être venus participer à
ce v y paie on se retrouve bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]